all
right
so all right we got disconnected there
for a second but we are back and okay as
you shared that I went through and
shared through your YouTube and
Instagram and then I pulled up the tab
on my website called solar Punk because
solar Punk is like this uh archetype of
where indigenous wisdom of Mother Earth
and unity meet with technology and
abundance prosperity for all and so it's
this super
inspirational alignment it's like where
where and how you can align yourself to
what is like the most beautiful um
highest possible timeline of of Earth
and and shattering every limit like we
were saying that's in the way of
that two SE brother there we go turn off
now yeah brother I'm loving what you're
saying keep yes yes uh did you turn your
radiator off it's actually got a little
bit colder it's like out the outside's
going up and the inside's going down so
yeah yeah I'm balancing with my mind
anyway it's all just uh anyway so let's
get back I'm really interested on tip of
the tongue so solar Punk yes indous
colliding almost alchemizing with this
um abundance of basically self-worth so
yes beautiful I've seen the images on AI
as well of just really just out
picturing of what we know is is more and
more true of a way that we perceive
ourselves that's what it feels like
right right yeah right yeah exactly I
mean that that's that's exactly it it's
like all the codes are inside and then
what happens is it's a clearing of all
of the ideas that are that that's not
possible right right who's who's the
rulemaker like let's try and find this
guy yeah yeah even we try and blame oh
it's Bill Gates oh it's this okay
whatever weird stuff's going on you can
never really find because it's all a
thought of what's what's possible so if
in yourself there's self-doubt there'll
be a manifestation of avatars that will
say certain things and it's just a test
to see your test of what you want for
yourself which is complete Limitless um
because like you say you you bring up um
basic needs met right I mean that that
that's a that's that's a selfworth thing
that's that's the ability to have a
certain level of basically also seeing
what is AB AB abundance isn't always
just zeros in your bank account it's the
ability to do what you want when you
want to do it so if you have that met
because you feel worthy of it because
everything's energy we are just a race
of uh just limiting thoughts of trying
to not see our our full potential it's
it's a real effort it takes to egoic
think you're limited yeah and so when
someone gets exhausted of that if
someone's really in that scarcity
mindset of um me me me m my M basically
that's rooted in fear that somehow they
need to keep securing some kind of
safety even though they're an infinite
indestructible being yes like it takes
so much it's actually a very skillful
thing that we've done on planet Earth to
really Overlook our Infinity yeah wow
they amazing the limiting of the
Limitless is the most fascinating thing
geez yeah and then like it's crazy cuz
the Limitless is like having this like
new this new Earth Utopia
and then the limited is like no no no
you know what the what exists now and me
me me my my my all all that kind of
stuff fear scarcity all those kinds of
things and there's basically you know
it's it's its own Collective hypnosis
into limits of all sorts and that's why
every single time that someone is like
getting a catalyst of like that little
video that pops up oh who's this guy
Matt Garrett and what is he talking
about and it's
like yeah and it's like yeah yeah yeah
either you know it's like oh my God no
or or it's like it pops you know it pops
a little bit of the programming and then
all of a sudden it's like wait a second
why why do I just why do I just agree to
all of this limiting stuff and yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a complete test of these
avatars playing out um your own test to
see your own conviction like I just say
thank you but you you do you and I'll do
me and if you want to if you see how I
see you'll see how I see now I've set my
frequency of what I believe in which is
always myself which is always yourself
so when you believe in yourself if
others aren't ready to step into their
own self trust it's always
selfworth self trust will replic will
mirror back to what you perceive
yourself to be worthy of receiving this
is a complete allowing of abundance it's
not a working for abundance there's no
graft here this is this is letting like
adamus is great as well I don't you
heard of St J adamus let let energy
serve you let this be an allowance
there's no becoming there's a shedding
of everything you're not you're a snake
shedding its skin but we we tend to
think oh we're little SCE snakes that
don't deserve any kind of anything but
like this planetry system is so insane
for Mastery it's so good because it can
go so dark it can go so started that
we've chosen certain and this is all
just a planet in our mind anyway this is
a complete dream of of a test just to
see our decision to choose love and
light over the darkness of fear because
even all of these things that come from
like a that those slly backdoor things
under the table okay you can say that
that all that stuff but it's still
they're rooted in fear they're rooted in
hatred they're coming from scarcity even
if they've got so much money in the bank
a lot of these beings who are just out
pictures of us a very still scarcity
mindset because if you're doing this
yeah you must have a feeling of lack you
know but abundance attracts abundance
when you start to see that abundance is
is not of just money of just your
well-being it's really a letting go of
just okay just [__] breathe and just
let it come to you yeah that's what
we're after yeah yeah we should start
ASMR ASMR now yeah we have some ASMR
content it's actually really beautiful
yeah I think remember it yeah yeah just
let it flow yeah let it
flow stupid
[Laughter]
human [__] Bill Gates
[Music]
man all the all the cucks the cucks in
their wealth silos not wanting to share
with the rest of us [__] them and
they're hoarding and they're [__]
egoic Tendencies to want to rule and
manipulate people and put chips inside
of their brains say become my zombies
become my slaves I will control all the
money systems and you will suck on my
testicles and I will escape into Ai and
space and upload
Consciousness right and that's just a
big old Karma thing they're building up
It's Just Energy patterns man there's no
even beings doing it's it's energy
patterns of negativity drawing and
negativity and you can choose what
reality you want to perceive like to a
certain extent as well I've started to
realize like because of my choice of
reality I'm constantly surrounding
myself with people like you or I walk
down the street and like you you start
to repel negativity because you're just
so hon like let's say you walk down the
street you're just so honest with
someone if someone's also got that self-
Honesty it's a match made in heaven and
you can just talk about anything and
everything now if someone's hiding parts
of themselves it's like when an ET comes
right if an ET with just pure light and
love if you're in the presence of of of
a being of that magnitude everything
that you're hiding has to come up to the
surface like the Blazing sunlight so
it's the same thing you know to an
extent obviously we're not saying we're
just crazy light beings but also the
self worth is saying yes this
Consciousness is very intensely aware
and so is yours and that's why you find
yourself surrounded by that I want to I
want to play hit this ball so okay so
this Pure Energy ramped up in frequency
to where it's just basically
obliterating all limits in the
collective that are uh Contracting it
into uh pre preventing it from being the
new the new Earth yes go ahead can I can
I can I say let's make the adjective
like just gliding past it's just a the
easiest thing when you really get
instead of expanding contractions or
breaking limits expanding is great just
obliterating you can say obliterating
whatever but to me it's just like a an
ease just like just don't want it
anymore you know oh nice yeah yeah nice
yeah yeah that's that's good yeah I mean
that's a fun perspective to have on it
in retrospect um because like during you
know it's always like the death of the
false and so that's yeah yeah yeah my
whole channel is me I have a video that
says [__] your parents [__] what anyone
thinks that that is limiting you you are
the savior of your own dream but then
it's like right okay that's still got
Yang like actually you know what [__] it
who am I to say what you say you're
giving this Yang energy that's amazing
I'm also just giving a bit of Yin as
well but some days I'm just like [__] it
yeah my speci calls it's like you know
some people actually need to be shaken
alive exactly like some people are just
so like timid but they want they're
counting on you to really shake them
away yes yes especially you've seen um
since 201 like 18 or so do you remember
when um Jordan Peterson became popular I
saw your videos with him yep yep do you
remember when um Andrew Tate became
popular like some years ago yeah yeah do
you do you see what's sort of happening
though is that there's the the masculine
that has been repressed and and also
that hasn't had a father right MH it is
uh using Jordan or Andrew or whoever
yeah manifestation yes manifestation as
the reflection of step into that godamn
divine power young man activate yourself
for a noble that transcends your selfish
and it's like [__]
yes have you heard of Luke belar by the
way
Luke Belmar b e l m a r no he's like
he's like the ne to me he's a very
clarified Andrew tape but but I wouldn't
even like I don't even want to like
compare people to other he's just got a
lot of wisdom coming from that same
demographic of people he's reaching so
he's could be a cool guy to reach out to
but um that's a good pin cool
yeah appreciate that so I I love this
topic because it's it's what you're
talking about there's been so much
suppression for so long of you could say
really when you go into the
incarnational remembrance of this whole
planetary system on one phase the the
feminine energy was oppressing the
masculine energy and then we're used to
this whole masculine oppressing the
feminine it's always a retaliation when
you go really far back to Isis and the
sex energy schools it's all this
woundedness um within the Collective and
so you're just seeing this all the time
right masculine feminine we're in this
where it seems though because we have
history books recently yes of course the
masculine oppress the feminine but there
was a time where it's other way around
so we all have these wounds inside of us
especially those with incarnational
balances being both sides knowing the
oppression so now we're dealing with the
wound of each so how how we how are we
to allow a wound to heal if we come back
with it fire but this is the great thing
Andrew takes manifestation of this
Frozen masculinity of um timidness not
wanting to you know it's usually
repression of anger authenticity honesty
conforming to some kind of like uniform
whatever this is not about Conformity
there is a breakout almost like when you
pop a like a zit or a spot it comes out
but then there's this right now let it
heal with the maturity that masculine
and feminine together they create this
conscious experience you can't you know
we've chosen these two energies to be
the the contrast of experience in order
to feel separate so now it's it's it's
like you'll see Andrew Tay every
planetary system has this like phase and
then it's like right let's guide this
explode at least it's juice now it's not
frozen right yes yes exactly right say
power man it's like so much energy to
create yes yes Sexual Energy as well is
is is Creative Energy that's frozen
that's a big trauma in the collective
yes yeah yeah oh my my gosh so good like
what does it look like when the that
that masculine energy that's willing to
to completely crucify all of its
selfishness but for the directionality
of New World prosperity for all what
happens when that gets activated in a
network that is millions of masculine
bodies that are that are just ignited
and also balanced this is that's really
the that's really the other part of the
thing is
that um the whole deconditioning process
it also includes learning what is the
yin energy inside what is the surrender
energy what is the feminine energy does
one does one know that embodied energy
the feeling the sensual does one know
that can one can one meet their fellow
brothers in that energy can they hold
and love their fellow brothers can they
be held and loved by their fellow
brothers this you see you see
relationship here right you see the
Andrew Tate um explosion which is great
right okay Andrew Tate has said a lot of
things that I don't agree with but he
he's a manifestation of this willingness
to be in uh Integrity honesty and also
um an eruption of Frozen energy right
okay so I only take I only take what I
resonate from people and if and I don't
disregard the whole of their message
just because I don't agree with you know
certain things he said which a lot of
the time is just to get traction for
videos and whatever but with with some
maturity you see that you don't have to
agree with everything but what he's
representing is this explosion but then
we're seeing a lot of these guys
listening to him are in this right yeah
eruption of all this energy but you can
see the temptation to them blame the
feminine blame this blame that and there
you can you can blame or you like and
sure there are dynamics where the
feminine can can do certain things and
and temp but we've all got feminine in
us anyway we've got masculine in us
anyway so it's just our own energies
playing out this crazy game so what I'm
interested in is now that this juice has
erupted to come into this creative flow
is really harnessing that energy not
just to go out and just sort of fle away
it's like what do we truly want with
this new found Integrity that we can now
stay in alignment with because it's the
alignment which which all these men are
coming into because when you're
repressing your your power and your
light same with same with the females
because they've got the masculine them
as well the discernment I don't you ever
come across I'm dealing this with my
sister at the moment I only really help
if she comes to me I'm saying look she
sometimes gets completely walked over at
work and I'm like you've got so much Yin
in you now stand up for yourself which
is a m which you know that it's it's a
strong feminine as well but also the
wisdom of the masculinity to be like you
know that's that's what's been simping I
will not be walked over yeah right it's
just selfworth we come back to the same
topic every time yeah yeah exactly so
that's that's where it's coming to a
complete
balance I love that like end of doormat
end of sing uh uh ignition of selfworth
ignition of uh highest timeline on Earth
um ignition of responsibility for
healing the planetary body and
activating it its Divine gifts like it's
it's that it's that like it's in a way
it's its own like punch it's like a
punch into
oneself uh and
like it's and it's okay because there's
going to be uh limits and those are
going to get cleared and that that's
that's a beautiful uh uh that's like the
that's you can say that's the nature of
biology and nature and infinity like
that's the nature of its of of its
process but the very fact that you
become constituted as something that
transcends yourself as the as what is
the whole or the totality and as
something that you can wake up every
single day and feel like you have a
Divine gift that contributes to it
like and and then you can be playful and
silly and balanced along the way and all
kinds of like dude what is better than
that like we that that is so like what
we want it's like it's ah yeah right and
you know what the best thing is when you
choose your reality those that don't
want to choose the same thing just won't
be a part of it they'll be in their own
reality and sometimes these overlaps
come you walk down somewhere you see
someone but more often than not they're
really not in your reality and less and
less you'll be able to stay in a
vibration that mirrors a certain way of
thinking that no longer serves you so
these narrow narrow Gates I always bring
it back to the narrow Gates because if
someone doesn't want to walk through a
gate that you are I get so many messages
like my girlfriend's not seeing as I see
and she doesn't want to be into this and
I'm just like you can't change anyone
all right F first of all don't try and
change them show up as you are as you
see as a demonstration of your clarity
if they're going to step into your light
they will if they're not ready to then
don't have this kind of uh [__] around
eggshells atude of I need to stay where
I am walk through where you want to walk
through why why would someone want to be
with someone unless they're going to
match their frequency of Truth and
responsibility yeah like like if you're
a
relationship Sometimes the best most
loving thing is to say no to to let
someone go and allow them to find
someone that could be a lesson for them
to then step into Clarity right so it's
always coming from Fear when hold on to
relationships even family members jobs
oh my God jobs so many people can tie in
this scarcity of like income which is a
very like I I hold my hand up relative
thing there there's there's if you know
honor your belief system where you're at
if if you're on your last dollar maybe
stay in your job a bit longer until your
belief systems can support you in moving
into a job that's in your alignment
where abundance is your self worth and
and it will it will serve you but you
have to take that step because the way
appears as you take the step step as we
all that classic phrase so for those of
us that have the courage just to keep
taking steps and we know that the ground
always supports us you start to run and
those that also run you look around it's
like me and you just running because we
we we trust ourselves because we're not
running on a ground that's outside of us
we are the ground yes yes we are the
path there's no separation yes yes yes
oh we are the path yes yes we are
hartter we are the path
Ron my one we are the
path paus oh this getting bad no more
hogw
jok I haven't even really watched Harry
Potter this is such a bere the bit that
you said about um getting over the limit
that we trap ourselves in walking on
eggshells I love that one I love I love
it when we get past the limit of egg
shells and like that's another level of
activation dude that's like some Super
Saiyan [__] when you learn how to get
past eggshells Bo come
here yeah yeah absolutely and then it's
fascinating because the whole reality
field warps to that because the ones
that are close to you will yeah either
leave or they'll actually begin um
vibing closer to that and
it's you know why sometimes I'll hold a
vibration with someone and the amount of
times I used to come down just to kind
of make them feel comfortable but then
you realize when you stay that they
actually match you a lot of the time and
you've just given them an invitation
into your light which is their light yes
yes so the amount of times I I had to
learn that they don't want you to make
them feel comfortable they're counting
on you to stay in your vibration which
is their higher vibration and then they
have a choice whether going to step into
this frequency of basically
responsibility for their own Freedom
that's always comes back
to so someone okay right let's say
someone's working on eggshells right the
classic is to come down and also work on
eggshells and oh you okay like but now
it's like right shaking someone and
being like look let's stop [__]
around what do you want out of life and
why don't you want it like because you
must want something more than what you
want out of life because you're putting
some kind of investment in a belief that
says can't have it yes yes yes like you
are just a [__] stock Trader that's all
it is so when you start investing in
yourself you start pursuing what you
really want which is your own freedom
and you talked about self selfishness
and I agree when you say the selfishness
with with a small s right the
selfishness which is a breeding but
there's actually I would say a
selfishness with a capital S which puts
your freedom first as the on self yes of
Limitless and that is a selfishness that
actually affects the field nice to step
into their own selfishness which
is yeah I love that I love that yeah and
then it also um either repels away the
small self or it magnetizes them for
their own uh unlimitedness into the
their capital S selfishness and it's
fascinating because what we said earlier
that lowercase selfishness is all about
consuming Mother Earth and the uppercase
selfishness is all about igniting Mother
Earth in
nature like ah
the fruits everything just m nothing
grows back
yeah I love that and I want to
um I want to play on the subject of um
this whatever whatever this is going to
be called we don't even know what it's
going to be called but it feels like
it's something like this this new Earth
Warrior Network or something like that
no idea but what so what do you what do
you think about this like okay so a
network of new Earth Warriors that are
coming from the same place so we see
each other as equals right well let's
let's zoom out even more and this all
heading towards social memory complex
right for for for this is experiment
you're you're you're laying the path for
that reality like even this this network
is a stepping stone always will be but
even that network is not even really a
stepping stone it will it will evolve
itself more and more so you right it's
not like some sort of just useless
stepping God does it itself
absolutely you're growing a tree and
that tree is then the platform for the
next tree you know like the branches you
could say more the branches gra each
other so let's say the 20th century
spirituality was a certain branch that
was rooted in emptiness teachings also
self but it was also very um sit on the
cushion and shut up basically and now
we're in 21st century where we've been
through these phases before in each
planetary system you go through the um
you re you you're born again as some
kind of unawake being but really you're
always awake but then you go through
again that you go through the emptiness
stage you go through the everything you
come into the scarcity mindset and then
you find yourself right we're even
younger in these bodies in this
Incarnation and we have time now within
this Incarnation with all the help from
the other parallel lives and the
ascended masters because we feel worthy
of it all of this energy I just have
constant it's not disconnected anymore
just constant downloads constant seeing
from sometimes they don't even say their
name it's just energy forms what I
really now know it is it's just the
higher self it's just it's just me as
the overso and all of our overs Souls
sometimes dripping in technology like
the amount of stuff coming up around
crystals Tesla has his own thing going
on which he's still feeding energy
through it's just an energy form through
Tesla you can just see it's always
service to the hole though like brother
if I could tell you the visions that
come through me every day it's just like
a patience game now like so much is
coming through and sometimes I want to
write all down and but this is actually
a test page
always come back like it's always going
to come through let's say crystals for
example we are just scraping the edge of
their properties for the electromagnetic
waves I mean this is a whole Topic in
itself and I feel
actually part of me is not afraid to
talk about certain things with without
protection of certain things but I feel
like this is a whole uh topic within
itself but I think we could do
technology and UFOs and and whatever but
even the systems of flight um UFO travel
all this stuff it's on our fingertips
brother like we know I can see the
blueprints it's the way that we um
attract the electromagnetic waves the
way we distort them and it allows for
anti-gravity whatever it's always going
to be service to the whole because then
you have transport then you have
interdimensional transport you got the
Bermuda Triangle which is just a portal
and you know it's [__] crazy but
we've got to really just narrow it down
into what serves to the whole and how do
we want to allocate our focus and what's
really your gift gift because you know
some of us have certain Gifts of unique
Expressions which will help the whole so
we've got to just really refine what it
is that we want to which is Limitless
like you could do you could do whatever
you want when it's when it's exciting to
you though that's the that's the real
juice The Passion of it yes yes nothing
really matters you know but we but this
is so exciting so [__] it let's Master
it I I love how um what's what's
emerging now is this what we're calling
like this new Earth Warrior network but
also it's this Dow side of things like
yeah let's talk about the network yeah
let good cool so well well I like what
you said there though because you're
also talking about the unique Blueprints
and the codes that are then to yeah yeah
I love that so um so I I really love um
the da so the Dow Vision a decentralized
autonomous organization right social
memory complex Etc that it's not owned
by anyone it's owned by everyone it's
just like the internet right so you have
like biology and Mycelia right and then
you have like the internet is kind of
like a mirror of that right humans are
just like that that's the same thing
it's just one body right now now the
layer beyond that what we're envisioning
is like what we're calling home da but
really it's just one Dow one social
memory complex of different Dows and
stuff like that they all have osmosis
and whatnot but so the point of the Dow
is to decentralize basic needs
infrastructures right so it's to help
people Homestead
and and live in communities where
there's nextg energy infrastructures
there's water reservoirs food forests
there's all of the core components
brother I'm getting Goosebumps because
this happen on so many planetary systems
so we've got to see that this is a
simultaneity of just choosing that frame
and you've you've chosen that because
you start see how do you know why this
world feels so alien because we come
from the Stars where there's no [__]
finite anything yes so we're trying to
fit into a box that we've chosen to drap
ourselves in of [__]
alien and like wait a minute it's my
arm yeah yeah yeah like literally the
sun yeah like the sunlight versus a box
yeah like yeah you come from the Stars
where there's no limitation of course
it's going to feel strange it's going to
feel the worst thing in the world yeah
okay so now so now let's um let's
say yeah well the our our Vibe is lit
for sure this is we're we'll be making
we'll be making more content for sure we
worked together before yes yes yes yes
yes yes do you know quite lonely
sometimes sometimes I'll know straight
away I've been working with people
before it's like going into a house
party where everyone's still drunk and
you're like we've worked together like
yeah yeah yeah but but what you're
realizing is the the higher mind will
start to unveil people's like what you
say un choose unfuck themselves start
unveil themselves at a very gentle rate
and so I'm not going to go in and say oh
yeah you're VAR from the 17th century or
you're this from like for example St
Jermain I've been working with st
Jermaine in different incarnations
within this planetary system in his
Mystery Schools right me going around
spewing that out to everyone doesn't
really help but the information I
learned from those mystery schools which
were just to do with the Alchemy of
transmutation the Alchemy in in the sex
um the sexual energies the masculine and
The Feminine letting energy serve you St
Germaine is overlooking this whole
period um of it all so of course we have
constant access to this ascended master
so that that here as well like there's
just a complete lit up frequency which
is a familiarity of um of something and
you know I've never met you before we've
start we we've we've been speaking for
60 something minut or like 80 minutes in
this Incarnation yeah but I know you
better than someone I've you know went
to with yes yes I love that no there's
no coincidence yeah yeah exactly exactly
and it's almost like you know we
purposely both of us knew that we could
easily like reach out to each other and
connect and stuff but there was the
palpability of what needed to uh cook
for for it at this exact time and for
this to be the first quote date and then
it's like when you really I'm not saying
we fancy each other but you know this is
the masculine Brotherhood but you know
we like a girl like if you just smash
straight okay this time's awful if you
have sex straight away it's just if you
start allowing that to really brew and
then here there's just this absolute
orgasm of insight and remembrance of our
Brotherhood love it it's just the same
thing it's like a edging only fans you
know it is yeah it is yeah we'll get a
nipple reveal soon yeah next video we'll
do it we'll do a live we got we got the
we got the uh commitment though second
second date we got a nipple reveal
coming second day is a little bit chilly
today but I'll do a snow nipple review
one day let's go let's go okay so so now
like I I love I love that so much like
being activated in all of the ways that
make it feel like um it's a Timeless
portal between these like quote bodies
in the network I love I love that and
now okay so
now now as
these as these bodies come together it
feels like there's sort of like a you
know we're calling this new Earth
Warrior Network this homeow this kind of
stuff it feels like there's sort of like
two quote two quote components to it one
of them is sort of this this really like
kind of what we've been talking about
like really just like punching in and
like shattering all those limits and
being like okay the hole is my body like
I got it like let's let's let's and then
now the other part of it is the um the
the building of the new world and the
new world infrastructures and
homesteading like dude all these
visualizations of these light cities and
the magnificence of them Etc so so now
yeah so now those are kind of the two
sides of the same coin of this of this
network of this social memory complex 4D
Consciousness type type B East but the
one thing about it that I love that is
unshakable is not only the
constitutionalization as that but it's
also the constitutionalization as equals
that's what I that's what I love like I
love that feeling right right do you
know why as well because that's even if
someone wants hierarchy what they truly
want is is not to be the same but it's
the same level in their own unique
expression of who they are so that is
the same it's the same but it's not
joining in like a dullness of like your
just awareness it's very much we Joy
join in joy we join in that but any kind
of hierarchy will always be there as a
Temptation you can't bypass this the
lower astrals will always be there to
just to start with at a certain point
you're in in frequency they can't even
reach you because you're in such a
frequency of love it just burns up you
know if like a little drop to get close
to the Sun can't get anywhere near it
but when you're not radiating in your
truth that it can get pretty close and
then you can start to feed on it and
then you just start to choose Distortion
whatever but but we don't want to bypass
it but me and you know through honesty
and Temptation you can see what it's
like you see like to have some kind of
status on YouTube to have some kind of
it starts off like status right I'm a
teacher you're the student right the
only reason people have teachers is to
render them useless until you see that
you are both a teacher and everything
exactly exactly yeah and the that's the
fascinating thing about quote this new
Earth Warrior Network and 4D Earth and
whatnot the fascinating thing about it
is that where it comes from where it's
anchored in is the Paradigm of uh if
someone comes that wants to quote be
punched back to themselves the first
quote teaching quote teaching is
that the the my role in interfacing with
you is for is for uh me to obsolete
myself as quickly as possible right and
so that's that's the difference I feel
like between quote like
attachment uh and
Outsourcing versus um sovereignty and
being punched back to Raw awakeness now
I love what you said there earlier too
where it's like this equal awakeness yet
uniquely blueprinted gifted playful
style textur you know what it's like we
we've tried these communities in the
past you've seen them in the 20th C
where that everyone's the same everyone
like a communist thing what we what what
you have to think of it is like it's an
organic Hive where everyone has their
you know everything's buzzing around
like I I went to I have a very good
friend Andrew we spoke out before and we
came to the same conclusion we were
really working together on just looking
at at Community what it meant to be a
new frequency of community which isn't
everyone falling into line it's almost
like a hive that's so organically
intertwined and you know is it is it I
don't like the word Utopia just because
people have taking it but it is a Utopia
of everyone being in their power because
power isn't Force Power is showing up in
your light and then
everything basically it feels too good
to be true for a lot of minds but it is
the only way um to really go through
this is not to fall into the sameness of
repression but to step into what your
you came here to to explore which was
your expression of divinity yeah and oh
man it's we're in for a ride like if you
choose if you choose that reality you
will and there'll be others that choose
a different one like I feel like this
point is so important that we actually
want to say it again in another way
which is that this is this is the quote
way to be a singularity and yet at the
same time be social memory be the
most yeah because what you see in the
singularity is the beauty of the
apparent different gifts and textures of
I got him right imagine you just had one
flower yeah yeah yeah or let's say rat
have you seen the film
Ratatouille a bit okay whatever a chef
any chef film if he's cooking up
something the reason something's
beautiful is because it has everything
balancing each other the sweetness of
the tomatoes imagine you just had pasta
like we know so deeply what the beauty
of life is the social memory complex the
way that we are in this way we're all
heading towards being the one being
which is a collective of the mind but
like Bashar says anyone can represent
the Christ Consciousness within
themselves as the Pinnacle of that but
then you can't be Jesus you be the
Christ that you are which is the same
energy but it's it's your own
extrapolation of the energy it's the
it's the same Pinnacle of that center
point of that Consciousness in that
overs Soul yes yes that's so good yeah
it's so good like what is found is the
same but that's expressing itself
wildly uh uniquely and like the flowers
in the garden the fireworks however you
want to just the tastes of the different
kinds of foods but like dude that's what
is the gift like the gift and being able
to you know come together because what
will happen in this quote Network by the
way what you said earlier [__] hit me
so good because I have friends I love
the analogy of the drunk party like I
have friends that are some of the most
brilliant systems Engineers that I know
are they're popping and they're and
they're like babystepping their way in
and these are the ones that are the the
the the core of the systems Engineers
for the new world and so what's
fascinating is that right now it's like
it's like slobbering drunk at the party
and I'm like and I'm like I yeah and I
just sober up right you're sober up I'm
I'm I'm there with them because they're
like they're like like waking up like
like stopping slobbering a bit and like
getting more and more polarized you can
say right they're activating more and
more to it but there's something so
tempting about like the slobber because
let let's let's actually briefly talk
about that because what the what the
quote Temptations of the slobber are are
um some sort of I don't know V all kinds
of programs that are not Christ in
essence but um some of the ways to break
them down are like I guess you're just
tripping balls on uh emptiness you're
tripping balls on all kinds of selfing
you're tripping balls on uh on all kinds
of not taking responsibility for the
collective's transformation but in
essence right and and then that kind of
thing always ends up in and at some
point it's like I it's like it usually
either goes all the way like that and
then kind of comes back for different
lessons or or it's hits that point where
it's so catalyzed that it finally um
jets Jets on over so I wanted to mention
how much I like that that analogy
because all of these people we could say
drunk and it's the same thing as saying
as as just infinite intelligence we've
draped ourselves by choice with a
certain amount of clothing right and you
may have really understood a lot of
clothing someone's still wearing a
certain amount but theyve taken off just
enough to really actually hear what
you're saying like a lot of these
feelings of limitation but they still
have some on them that's still like wow
this feels quite warm and nice but
you're offering them what they really
want which is their decision to step
into this because they incarnated in
order to have these gifts of being an
engineer of being this thing and they
know it otherwise they wouldn't be
interested in what you're saying tell
[__] off and they get back to their jobs
or whatever so what we do is we don't
force anything like you know this as
well like you you you you remind them of
what they are their infinite capacity
like it's always empowering like yes yes
exactly yes they have so much
intelligence like I don't have that
engineering intelligence I don't want
that engineering intelligence I have my
own stuff that I'm bringing to the
collective as myself and so do you and
I'm sure ours kind of overlap and then
then yours overlap with the engineers
and and it's all this kind of just Hive
of again yeah yeah it's just Master like
this is also we can take away the drama
like this is just the like we okay we
have all these dark energies right which
are just distortions of light there's
only light anyway and we can take away
the drama and see that really this is a
Mastery of this next phase like we are
cleaning through it and if you're in my
reality it means we're really cutting
because all I'm choosing is Clarity
right now and that's all I want and
anything that comes near to tempt is
always just fuel to alchemize into
greater Clarity yes because Distortion
is just condensed Clarity so it's more
fuel for me you know it's all more fuel
for The Collector exactly exactly wow
yeah that it's great cuz like um what
our our mutual friend Nikki who's you
know we feel like is this core part of
our Warrior Network that's emerging and
whatnot
that we like to talk about like AIS and
like these little up like AIS in the
bodies of lions or whatever however you
want to say it and like and like like
these these AIS go through these like
updates right and it's like whatever
whatever's dived into yep whatever's
dived into it clears transmutes and like
it's done yeah and it's done so in this
like mirror Network right it's a mirror
Network and that's but that's like the
quote Foundation is that it's non
hierarchical it's equalized and yet it's
also so brilliant in the way that it's
the gifts are are are being activated
and coming alive and um man that like
dude this networks this this thing
whatever that thing is is like it's like
the thing that uh has been spoken or
like whatever it's already here like
that that thing like that's it's like
when we come Together We Come Together
from that place and that's what makes it
like um we have another friend you know
anog always talks about it it's like
when you come onto the field the playing
field you know you know the battlefield
you know for a fact that it's absolute
alignment between you and your teammates
it's like absolute alignment like right
yeah that's and that's like nothing can
nothing can replace that right yeah I
love um so yeah me and Cole have had a
lot of chats and it's the same exact
it's always the same thing because the
beings in the same frequency or or
similar frequency Chew in the same
reality are going to be attracted to
each other like it just happens in just
conversations just talking about this
and so what we're speaking about here is
a frame that we seem to be in a frame
that we know that we want and so
everything that's in denial of these two
frames let's say from to get to what
we're at which is which is here the
other frame's already here it's just
being actualized so everything that's
kind of let's say any kind of
distortions any Shadows seems like right
now it's intensity because it's coming
right up to the surface you might find
conflict between teachers you may find
certain teachers fall into traps of
Temptation you may find other teachers
do I'm not I'm not saying anyone is or
anyone isn't but I'm saying there's
definitely teachers that I've come
across which I don't agree with but
that's because they're aspects of myself
that are playing out my own inner worse
feelings about myself and so I have
another opportunity to alchemize that
Darkness into greater Fuel and they have
the honesty and the
responsibility um to see their own
distortions and they have to be honest
with their own distortions because what
they truly want is freedom and so I can
only love this person into realizing
what they truly want you know I give
them free will to choose the reality
they want to be in now if they taste
what it's like to blame right I want
them to taste it fully and see if that's
what they want if they want to make the
Free Will choice to choose the reality
that they want which is even playing
fields which is love which is me seeing
you as you are which is Christ you
seeing me as Christ and together as one
we come together sure but that has to be
founded in honesty and responsibility
for the maturity of who you are which
doesn't see anyone as less than you yes
we're all Christ so that's all I care
about perfect you know yes it's just the
only way that works for me I've tried
the other ways trust me tried blame I've
tried rejection I've tried it and you
can only say it when you've tried it if
you haven't tried it you still think
there's something for you in in division
yeah yeah there's nothing in division
but more hatred I love this yes yes oh
so good
good oh my
goodness oh my gosh it's yeah relating
uh as Christ to Christ as source to
source as it to it always always always
always and um yeah I do want to say one
thing actually there was a certain um
and I don't want to name names but there
was a certain point where this person
was saying things about Nic which I
wasn't happy with and so this is the
kind of thing where you step up and you
say this is a distortion from my
perspective
and and when someone crosses a line in
that way there's a way that you see that
they're coming from a place that you may
not agree with and so your only uh
ability here is to stand in your truth
of what you believe in and not have the
free will exposure to say Well they're
wrong but also to say look if we get
into name calling of these things there
must be something that isn't being seen
there because projection never works you
know this is always coming from the
heart which is saying the truth of
clarity and so you know we have we have
these range of teachers I know we were
going to say complete transparency and
and I love transparency as well as I
speak I don't feel as though we have to
indulge in the darkness people know who
they are people know what they've said I
love everyone even on both sides because
I see where they're coming from but I
also see Distortion so clearly these
days that I know what everyone really
wants which is what I want is truth and
so we can do another video maybe more of
a round table thing I think I never like
the reason the reason this is I always
say I don't like speaking about someone
unless they're present so if we want to
do a round table it or some way or we
want to maybe even just do like a i I'd
like to call with people privately as
well then we can get into this whole
intensity of drama we talk about the
mechanics of it here I find you know I
and I I feel like this is in a way where
we get to shine as our as our unique
gifts because I like grabbing by the
testicles and bringing right into the
fire I like that so much I like um I
like like igniting the very
purification raw and like even if even
if it's not present like and and I think
I think division for for me division has
become very uh it it quote like what it
like how do I say it it was something
that was a straight jacket is is a way
to put it like I would use not dividing
not creating more separation not
creating contrast not creating
discernment I would use that as a way to
escape into pure equinity and right and
then there was something liberated and
it and it and it it did it did feel like
it was hugely through the through my own
reflection to myself through the
mouthpiece we call naris where there was
just such a roaring of like unlimited
mouthpie that was like dude that's here
too like dude that's here too like unlim
mouthpie let it [__] flow and then so
then what was seen is that actually the
division thing it can be its own
straight jacket where for example like
being able to say and of course there's
all kinds of quote purifications into
that Network space that we were talking
about absolutely just you know
disclaimer there too of course but like
not creating hierarchy when you're
around equals and all kinds of [__] like
that yes of course yeah um but this sort
of this sort of idea of I will quote um
suppress creating division or creating
discernment or contrast or whatever is
actually something that that like that
fatherly masculine that's disciplined
and that feels like kind of God's Wrath
in terms of against Injustice like quote
division you could say that well and I
saw that you like this content but that
the rage against
pedophilia is quote creating division
right cuz you're saying that that script
is Satan you have but you have to say
that in order to kind of the the
Consciousness that that is trying to
kind of like understand how satanic that
is and to break itself away from those
those extreme contractions that are
there um and to to liberate them like so
so that kind of thing or like whatever
whatever anti-matrix stuff you know if
I'm making the those little videos that
are like beep beep boop boop Matrix
Matrix scattle beep beep boop boop you
know it's just it's poking fun at what
is the scripts that are that are simping
to Daddy government or D daddy
Corporation or whatever and and it's
just it acts as its own Catalyst but
it's only when the mouthpiece is freed
that it can quote use contrast to
generate Catalyst for transforming
towards that new Earth Network this this
is this is exactly what I'm interested
in which is true discernment and true
honesty and so the parts that I was
speaking about before which I want to
completely talk about because I feel
like there's an Alchemy going on right
now within the teacher space which is
just beautiful for the transformation to
Clarity so this whole pissing about with
names look we've got myself Nicole you
nagas maram you know you've got lots of
stuff going on you got bentino's Camp
all these amazing people bringing their
perspectives on it right and of course
theyve got Frank as well beautiful Frank
Andrew H you've just got so many high
frequency just Consciousness is coming
through right so of course there going
to sometimes be friction because
everything's coming to the surface of
what we need to alchemize of what's
still kept in the Bank of division so we
can't bypass like you say because if we
bypass [__] facing what seems to be
conflict we're just back into
suppression so this is TR I call it true
discernment where we what we want is to
head on head on with the conflict let's
let's bring up the conflict but then see
where's the distortion like where's the
dishonesty like we want pure honesty
pure integrity and so there's no blame
and projection but I'm still we just
want to bring it to the surface because
all I'm interested is everyone seeing
themselves as the empowered Christ
there's any friction it's just like
there's this bits of selfworth lacking
in certain areas maybe points and I
don't care about projection I just want
like you to stop pussying around in the
points in the field of let's say
pedophilia for example that's a
manifestation of just pure self-hatred
out picture sexual wounds everything
right so of course it has to come up it
wants to be indulged in it wants to be
repressed like you should see like the
different I I don't if you know much
about like the Scandinavian countries
the way that they treat criminals for
example they see them as patients they
see them as sick sick in the head they
have something wounded within themselves
and so we said with discern we say
that's a very wrong thing to an you know
very distorted this action a
manifestation of them not seeing
themselves clearly but we don't have to
associate or it's more just that you
don't disown that as part of yourself
but you forgive it within your own mind
but then you then these energies in
these energies energetic ways that try
to tempt you you alchemize them and you
you attack them head on and you see that
ultimately they're wanting to come to
the surface that's why there's so much
intensity in the world today yes yes yes
we're speeding up the timelines yes yes
yes yes yes it's
[Music]
surfacing and in the discernment I love
that like the we call you know we've
been calling Elegance you know or Grace
you know that that kind it like it
merges it merges the fatherly discipline
and like surgical but with that the kind
of the the elegant into some sort of
Elegance and Grace of the of the mother
yeah yeah the Ser the kind of like the
serving the nourishing the love and
respect you know um man you know it's
it's just something something like yeah
something like that yeah and and it
feels like that that Network it's not
going to it's not going to repeat the
same mistakes as the shadow
governments and as the shadow spiritual
systems because it's obvious that like
the oso Community like everyone knows
that as an archetype of what happens
when it's it turns into that kind of a
thing everyone knows like everyone sees
it it's just it doesn't merge it doesn't
merge with um with uh like an like the
the new new Earth Warrior Network or
even in Shadow governments it's not
merging as equals it's complete Banker
political oligarch plutocrat
hierarchies and so and so that those two
things they're just shadowy aspects that
are like being reflected and cleared for
the emergence of what is um
the way that we can relate to ourself
you know we're relating to ourself but
from the place of being
fully in tune with how to interface with
our self in in Divinity and in
manifesting our gifts of the new world
like dude there's nowhere to go I always
laugh dude it's like every there's
people that want to quote go oh out of
out of it and it's like dude it is
already that but in the body like so
where are you
going right right right that's Escape
yeah yeah where are you going right the
the manifestation of the structure which
is really more of a decentralized it's
just a complete reflection of how you
feel about yourself and therefore it has
to manifest to the reality you want so
when you choose that for yourself
naturally your highest excitement and
your alignment will be for this um
reflection of of an earth or whatever it
is the earth already every version of
Earth exists we are tuning to that which
we want so everything that's in between
that has to be purged or you could say
more accurately alchemized because
there's only light and this light
becomes so dense and it's kind of like
folds back in on itself and these
structures form like the oo thing but
these are just almost like release
points for that like they're like
learning lessons next one you know
I love osho's teachings right what
happens behind the scenes of course I'm
not I haven't got it's not I haven't got
true discernment of where I cut the line
of what I'm involved with that Community
but it's osho's teaching right there's
there's truth in everything now it's
seeing the discernment of what doesn't
work which is certain ways that people
idolize I mean look at [__] hierarchy
man like he was he was put on a pedestal
for the most out of like anything I can
see in Guru culture but we had to go
through that because prior to that we
didn't know of that shadow within us as
much like this whole Guru culture so now
we see it so now me and you are in this
uh Century of well what do we want do we
want that again no I don't you know like
[__] that like we we saw the code
manifest to learn that that's that's not
it either and now yeah yeah yeah how are
you gonna know what the path is if you
don't know the dead end right yeah yeah
exactly nice right do do you um by
chance have to go in five minutes at a
hard end or no I was going to say I
would probably just get like another a
drink so I could do like a maybe like a
two minute three minute break get a
drink what do you what do you think
about
um what do you think about
rapping uh and then we can just kind of
play like offline for for a bit sure
yeah should we yeah brother should we do
that okay cuz I was thinking we've been
like dude we just fired out like such
a gemstone like episode like covering
it's so good man yeah we went deep on
this one it's just the frequencies man
yes yes yeah there's so much going to
come through a lot of points at this
next phase so yes um how about we how
about we do that so I'll uh let me bring
up
the let me bring up your uh your this is
in the link these links are in the
description we got Matt's YouTube
channel go subscribe check out some
content there we we got his website also
we have his
Instagram and all those links are down
below and also of course we talked about
this the solar Punk stuff that link is
below also and
um let's
see
um oh we've been getting so much love in
the chat so much love back to you all
thank you so much for tuning in family
it's wow it's been so ignited so cool
love you we love you
too we love you too yeah I can't see the
chat but I love you too yes yes that's
something that I will look into putting
into maybe I hold on oh incle messages
now oh yeah yeah yeah you would have to
have it open and silenced or something
over yeah I'm feeling the love or I
could bring it on screen yeah
um so cool um any uh I'm I'm just I'm so
excited to keep creating together yeah
[__] yeah yeah yeah we set up in the
script to ripen because if um yeah you
always know because it lights up your
spine and there's something that um
comes together
freak hell yeah man you know you know
when you you know when you find the
others and there are no others and then
you turn you're in you're in the house
party the drunkenness you find someone
else sober it's like wait a minute we
can work together soing up everyone
else and it's like you you just like
walk around like showing the image like
the Hologram of the new world like
mirror mirror see how drunk you
are shaking some people like replacing
the spirits with water like just just
dropping around yes yes yes oh so good
house Mar baby yes yeah so freaking
excited for our Brotherhood and
co-creation so let's uh this is our our
rocket ship our blast off and thanks
everyone for tuning in and and yes much
love and we will see you
soon share share the content if it
brought uh value share it with people
who you think it would bring value to
comment below with your thoughts on it
like the video subscribe you always know
all right
peace peace out all right brother one
second we will stay in